in five four three two boys crack son of
a [ __ ] three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we have a very
special guest here today and I'm super
excited now I gotta say there are a very
few people in this world that I meet
instantly and I connect with super fast
and this piece of gay girl right here is
here her name is Eunice hello Eunice hi
David so we're talking to you in a very
formal setting because when we first met
I just started thrashing you the first
day that I met you oh yeah
no the first time you met me you were
really civil really yeah in what way it
was just you and me in the wardrobe room
and you were so nice and asking me about
my life and everything and then as soon
as you're in front of other people it
was like you know why your hands are
massive well it's because I was trying
to be nice and keep you keep you
comfortable and then I saw your massive
hands and the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me you
know that tsunami that happened in Japan
was because you would did a round of
applause that [ __ ] just destroyed
oh so yeah the reason why I have unison
well number one we do the genius brain
podcast like I like bringing people that
I personally know because I feel like
everybody has personal stories and this
girl is giving me [ __ ] because it's
Pride Month and she goes David you
should talk about Pride Month and I'm
like yo I could talk about that but me
not being a gay male I I don't have a
lot of words for it so like last week we
somebody asked the question they go what
would you do if you were if you if one
of your kids were gay and for me that
answer was very straightforward it was
nothing who cares move on right so I
couldn't really put into words why that
would be a big deal why did they ask the
question what was their perspective
there wasn't a perspective they were
just wondering what would you do and I
you know because we allow people to come
on to this this podcast and ask
questions for us and see how he would
handle that situation but for me I feel
like because I'm a Cali boy and in
California is tense we're very liberal
here so it doesn't really cross my mind
as an issue you know what I'm saying so
I don't think so if my kid was born gays
just kids gay well I think you're so
opinionated so they probably asked that
because they thought they would get more
more of a response
I mean we tried talking about it and I
guess because we it was me and two other
people mm-hm
and it was just I wouldn't say I was at
a loss for words but it's not something
that comes to my mind as an issue right
so it's just so if my kid came out to me
goes dad I'm gay I'm like all right well
you want for dinner you know you know
[ __ ] move on with I mean that's
really progressive of you I don't know
if it's really progressive I feel like
very Californian me and well maybe I
don't know well your situation because
my parents live in California and it's
that's a whole other story got to know
about this just because I don't I talked
about this coming-out story where my one
of my friends brother came out to us
while we were playing like a basketball
game and yeah I didn't put any sandbags
on there but we he got mad at us I guess
he ruined his coming-out moment but the
reason why was because we knew he was
gay right and he goes hey I got
something important to tell you guys I'm
gay and we were just yeah we [ __ ]
know move the [ __ ] out of the way the TV
you know I think he's still upset with
his brother till this day cuz he still
mentions it in jest but you know to his
brothers defense it was we already knew
and we already loved you so you're
trying to make this big I don't know if
you're talking to the right family cuz
mom and dad know I knew so you I guess
in his mind he goes he's been very
dramatic since he's a little kid and he
was you're you coming out it's not new
to us so I guess for them he wasn't
trying to ruin his moment but he was
more on his side was like you're making
a big deal out of nothing you're gay
cool move on we're trying to play a game
yeah I think that goes two ways like one
you're not giving someone the space and
the openness to show you who they are in
a way that is safe for them mm-hmm and
then the other hand I think I would have
preferred that because it's just a form
of acceptance yeah that where it's just
unspoken and they know something about
you that you've held onto for so long
and they just completely accept it to a
point where it's like well we already
know let's move on yeah I know like I
say she wears a phallic object something
you're not used to
yeah and so for in his in his mind he
was just if you were trying to hide that
you were gay you did a very bad job
that's pretty much and for us too we
ought we assumed that he was pretty open
about it but I guess he wasn't
quote-unquote open because he never had
that formal opportunity to tell his
family but they had Gabe they had gay
people in their family already so
they're not are they Korean no their
Filipino oh so there he had openly gay
members in their family so it wasn't
something that was a big deal it's you
know they've already went through this
maybe a couple of times but I didn't
mention this in the podcast before but
they already went through it a couple
times so it was alright your cousin's
gay you know right right and his cousin
have a coming up moment either it was
just I'm gay guys it goes go what do you
want for dinner oh you know well that
family is really progressive is it yes
maybe I mean I think for Korean people
it's difficult right for sure for sure
for sure I mean what's it been like for
you I mean I don't even know your let's
just start from the beginning only
because this is so this is so unique
okay and just because I feel like a lot
of kids they they may not know how to
deal with this situation when you were
younger and I'm sorry let me turn off my
phone when you were younger when when
did you kind of I don't know how to ask
but when did you know well I think I
knew when I was about six damn that
something wasn't quite right I think I
think this is the really sad part is
that society trains you to like certain
people and so when you're not exposed to
certain things like the lgbtqia+ world
the what it's like there's more letters
which I ate was IA it's intersex an
asexual what say say xxxx women's you
not attracted anything yeah okay led tqi
a TLC a cheesy type right we just put a
plus sign there now because there's
gonna be more well possibly I think it's
an inclusive or
right so okay anyone who's not cisgender
and identifies with what society tells
them is part of the LGBTQIA we'll come
back to that later okay so I knew when I
was about six and then I didn't really
even explore it until college
damn and then I went to school in New
York so it was apart from my family and
it was a it was a chance to really kind
of come out and come into myself but I
didn't even really explore it until the
very end of New York and then when I
went to London to do my Master's that's
kind of when I really allowed myself to
discover that part of me of me so when
you you said from six all the way till
you was that till you left the house
yeah you've never explored your what
homosexuality for that many years yeah
at all like you just none at all
did you think did you know so did you
definitively know you were gay or you
just thought that you just were a little
different I didn't really understand
what it was yeah so from 6 to 17 because
17 I left for New York I had I didn't
even know anything about the LGBTQ world
mmm right there's nothing around me
that's that has anything to do with
homosexuality and everything that that's
on TV or the radio and and I grew up in
a really Christian household you know
and my parents were extremely strict
well my dad went to work and my mom
stayed home with us so I remember when
she'd leave the house she'd be like you
guys have to read so she'd tape up the
electrical cords so we couldn't watch TV
Dale yeah like she was extremely strict
and then the radio we didn't really
listen to secular music until I mean 15
16 men you were really close then yeah
that's crazy because my father's a
pastor he didn't do that stuff actually
maybe 14 cuz high school it's when my
sister was two years older than me and
she drove me to school so obviously at
the radio
stuff but yeah before that nothing damn
yeah so wait when your so okay so you
didn't get to the secular music right so
no secular music your mom would wrap up
the course so you couldn't watch TV or
anything like that and she would just
make you that's as stereotyped asian as
[ __ ] possible it is yeah that was my
that was my upbringing that's okay okay
so then after that you went to you went
to college in New York and what were you
studying I studied design and management
at Parsons so I actually won in she just
likes to slip that in by the way no I
went in for advertising okay right and
but that was the time of Project Runway
and it was really lit at the time and so
every resource that Parsons was in
fashion okay
so initially I try to fight that and
resist it and then ultimately because
every opportunity was in fashion I ended
up doing my first internship mhm and and
then I think it was an internship at
women's wear in LA where I really fell
in love with styling and I was able to I
mean I didn't even know what it was I
really didn't know that the well pages
of magazines were creative really
creatively directed by these people and
so for me once I discovered that and
started really enjoying it I mean I was
I mean I'm a really like stubborn shot I
was really stubborn too it was like I
like this this is what I'm gonna do for
the rest of my life and I'm kind of
stuck with it yeah so for you when after
you left and you were in college and you
went into you went to London was that
like I guess it was very permissive of
you to just figure out who you were Yeah
right well I gave myself the permission
yeah so it was finally okay I'm far
enough from my parents now anything I do
here it'll be like carte blush I don't
have to worry about you know like
running into my parents or my parents
friends there was no chance of that so
it really allowed me to be completely
free and in that way and because of that
I came out to everyone around me very
quickly how was it what did that feel
like did you cry yeah I cried
probably like the first ten people I
told I cried Wow what what why do you
why do you think you cried like what's
the what's the emotion in the feeling
behind that I think it's finally being
able to reveal yourself and I didn't
really cry to new people so yeah so in
the beginning stages of when I was
coming out when I first met people I
felt like I had to immediately tell them
like it was my is my duty because in
case they knew me for five minutes or
more it's like I would have held on to
this lie about myself oh yeah which is
really bizarre and now I don't tell
anyone unless they ask me and I'm not
ashamed of it but I don't know why it's
anyone's business or maybe it's because
you know like you said like because of
the the first few years of your life
everything felt like a lie so in that
moment you just when you first meet
somebody you want that moment of honesty
right it's not for them it's more for
yourself it is and so when I was coming
out to people so I had some friends come
to London and then we'd go out and the
whole time in my head I'm thinking I'm
gonna tell them that I'm gay and I
remember my friend Monique my friend
Monique came in from New York and I've
known this girl the whole time I was
that person she I think she was the
first girl I met at Parsons hmm and she
came and we're sitting there it's this
out outdoor pot I just remember it so
vividly we were in Notting Hill we're
sitting outside we must have like topped
off like three bottles of rosy and I
could I didn't want to stop because in
my mind I thought okay I just need this
liquid courage to get through this but
then I was getting really drunk yeah and
you don't want to do that in in a moment
of reveal because your emotions are out
of control or sure and so I finally get
the nerve I just couldn't take it
anymore I think it was like hour three
and I said look my neck I'm gay and she
looked at me and she said oh that's good
anyways yeah I know but she don't say
anyways like she let me have it but she
really and I remember feeling so
appreciative and I still feel
appreciative to her because I think that
was that was one of the benchmarks of
how I knew how to come out to some
and knowing like I know that the
anticipation is a lot scarier than the
actual words and the results hmm and so
she said you know Eunice I kind of I
kind of had an idea and her boyfriend at
the time who's actually still her
partner now he said he apparently had
always known yeah he goes you're gay as
[ __ ] it's like finally say I knew he
liked rajadi but looking at my [ __ ]
girlfriend like for the past three weeks
tops Terry oh no you know I never
attracted to any friends for me it was
either I meet someone and I try to get
to know them romantically immediately or
it reset develops into a friendship and
then I don't know like do you ever feel
attracted to your friends or don't feel
like you could have a relationship with
them no because when I when I meet my
friends and we cut it when we meet in in
that type of way I know all the good and
bad about well that's exactly it already
in your mind you're painted goods I'm
like I know way too much about you like
you are not somebody that I want to deal
with implement and I feel like for me
when I my first girlfriend was my best
friend and that it's almost like I knew
too much about them I think yeah I think
that's a real roadblock to getting to
know someone and developing feelings
yeah I think there's really incredible I
really respect people who develop this
friendship and get to know the good and
bad about someone and then still feel
that attraction you know because for me
that's never been the case yeah I can
see that yeah I mean so when you that's
so interesting that when you when you
kind of had like this very permissive
moment you just want to tell her listen
dude I'm gay I'm gay hey did I tell you
I'm [ __ ] gay right it's a it's a way
of slipping it into the conversation and
then you can kind of gauge their
reaction yeah so I mean in London you're
meeting new people all the time like
constantly it's not I feel like LA's are
really bubbled society where everyone
has their friends from a long time ago
and everyone's had these long lasting
friendships and everyone feels like new
people want things from them but in
London it's so free and
when you meet someone they could become
your best friend the next day yeah and
so in this society it was me telling new
people like people that I had no skin in
the game with basically and dropping it
in somehow like well you know my my ex
or something or you know just something
where they get the picture of oh this
girl is queer she's not she doesn't like
men and and I would just do that with
everyone I met for a while is it
offensive is is gay an offensive term
you know how like people have certain
adjectives that they don't want to hear
nice would it be queer cuz I don't know
no queers like all-encompassing okay I
think and I think no I think gay gets
thrown around a lot and I don't I
personally don't find it offensive I
think that there's this stigma with
people in previous generations where
yeah I mean that was a slang word to use
for everything I mean when I was young
too we used you're gay that's gay for
everything yeah but when you're using it
in the proper form now and I guess
unless you're using it as an attack like
it shouldn't be an offensive word yeah
but I only speak for myself of course
yeah I mean that's all anecdotal it
depends on where you are it's like when
like people to touch on this topic all
the time is like the usage of the n-word
right some black people okay with this
some people aren't I you just have to
kind of feel out your social your social
network understand what that's what are
you using it no I said blood went black
people oh I see with each other right no
but even like Asian or Mexican people
right like in Sacramento I grew up where
everybody used that word and tell this
day everybody's still you really to this
day but like how I explained it to was
that the odd part about it is people's
incessant need to say it right it's so
if somebody comes up they go yo man like
I don't like it when you say that cuz it
offends me and then you come back with
why not it's more like okay well what's
your what's the point of that
like what's what does that really do for
you and why do you need to say it for
example for me I grew up saying it my
whole life and I've cut that down by it
like 99% I'm not gonna say that I don't
use it occasionally every now and then
when I'm with my friends from back in
Sacramento because everybody uses it it
just slips out right and they don't have
a problem with it
they even find it weird sometimes when
we don't use it anymore it's almost like
who are you trying to be because we grew
up saying our whole lives
yeah you don't hear me saying it at all
almost never right because times have
changed and I'm a lot smarter about it
because of the way it makes people feel
so that's why I like for example I
didn't know that [ __ ] was an offensive
term yeah I didn't know that we actually
found out through it JK news episode
we're like oh well that [ __ ] and then
they're like oh and this person was
there was somebody who was a part of
this the I guess a you too that was a
part of like the transsexual community
with a transgender I don't know I just
an ally I know they were okay I think so
they're super vocal a lot like yeah
they're just so instead I was like well
first of all this was seven years ago
and how will how would we have known we
wouldn't have known because it wasn't in
the spotlight yet so everybody was
living in ignorance at that point and
this is prior to like YouTube really
being big and so my issue was that was
instead of getting angry you took a
chance you took an opportunity to
educate us in the worst way possible
because we didn't know right and I think
sometimes I get mad with people when I
always look at intent so if somebody's
intent is right but they just didn't
know then you should have that
opportunity to let them how did you use
we just used the word [ __ ] like it was
no one was like well this person is a
[ __ ] no I didn't [ __ ] know it's for
example I have a couple of friends from
Canada right big they were he called you
know what [ __ ] restaurant do you want to
go to I know but the do didn't know that
[ __ ] was an offensive term for Japanese
people he was shortening like Vietnamese
and Viet so you know did I I didn't get
mad at him mmm-hmm you know and I asked
him I was like oh did you know that's
like an offensive term that's like like
a world war two type of slang like to a
very derogatory term right these people
he goes oh I had no [ __ ] idea I
didn't get mad at him it's just there's
a reason why he used that word yeah
because it didn't sound like he was
trying to offend anybody just came out
well I think it's circumstantial too
because maybe when you say it to him
he's like okay woah I should never use
that again but then you never know maybe
the next time he uses it I mean it I
guess it's but you can't you I guess
what I'm saying is I can only do what I
can do now and I can't I'm not
responsible for what that person does
after right but I can take that moment
to somebody kindly about it sometimes
too I meet old people with where they
say mad races stuff and I could tell
that their intent is really nice just
because they grew up in a different time
so I'm not gonna sit there and scold the
70 year old man for asking me what the
best Chinese restaurant is around this
area you know it's just more like it's
very innocent I understand you know so
for me intent goes a long way
yeah um because it's just I think
there's a lot of missed opportunity for
people to really speak civil to somebody
else about something that they don't
know and he just kind of creates like
this big division which I don't like you
know so I agree coz back in the day I
used to word gay all the time I mean I
feel like I must have to not that I
remember any specific moment but we used
to I mean that used to be one of our our
words it was our top word date yeah it
was gay and [ __ ] [ __ ] was a big one
well so was the R word [ __ ] yeah you
know what I understand the whole [ __ ]
thing because [ __ ] is a it's you could
use [ __ ] in a different way like not
maybe not for a person but you could say
like this this this phone is [ __ ]
because you say that but you what about
if it's just an inanimate object it's
not a person is that is that bad yeah
why because I think it's because
everyone's initial idea of what that
word is is it disabled like person I
understand that but the word
definitively can be used for as an
adjective for things I think that's if
like something's askew right yeah like
so if my phone is not working I just
thought exactly [ __ ] I would just
say stay away from that well with my mom
called me [ __ ] my whole life and it
didn't really affect me that much she
would always tell me Punk
well no but that means disabled no it
means because you you wouldn't say the
you wouldn't use the r-word for someone
whose leg is broken but you would say
pill machine for someone whose leg was
broken Hank you would say you got a
[ __ ] Escalade right
oh my god I'm kidding by the way people
this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but
when you what was um I don't know if
you're okay I'm just gonna ask this if
you're okay
what was that when was the first time
that you have I guessed
wait did you did you date any boys you
know this yeah I did
I had boyfriends in high school I do it
but I can't remember and then in college
it was so that was my moment of
discovery of trying to like penis who is
good-looking
looks like like a baby's arm holding an
apple what is this is that so the date
looks like it looks like a baby holding
a little baby Apple looks like cats with
veins on it a very muscular baby's on No
so when you so when you were going
through those experiences it was just
more like you know you don't feel like
an emotional connection you don't feel I
never felt you know this is really weird
and I've never actually talked to anyone
about this but I there's a difference
between connecting with for me with a
woman versus a man in what sense with a
guy sometime and I don't know where this
comes from and maybe it's because I'm a
neatly born gay but for me as a when I
meet with a man it's I feel a level of
having a wall up and if they violate
that space in any way it scares me
mm-hmm and there's something there's
like a trigger in my body that's like
you're not safe you don't like this
isn't for me it's really it's bizarre I
can't really explain it but I have a lot
of really close friendships with males
but I don't ever think about anything
further that's because you're gay this
is because you're gay no I understand
what I'm trying to tell you like this
this alarm system that goes off because
you're gay
when I went out when a man comes up to
me as a heterosexual male he gets an
inch away from my face
an alarm system goes off - he goes what
are you doing so you get it then you're
gay
well okay so going back to my childhood
so I was brought up and my dad who I
respect very much he has always brought
his children not to be well he has two
daughters so women of agency so he's
always said you know what do you want to
be when you grow up you can be anything
you want and he's always encouraged us
and he's never put us down on any ideas
that we might have about our futures and
I think because of that were really
headstrong but we're also really sure of
who we are and what we want to be and I
think that directly contradicts to what
my parents want from us now but now I'm
like well it's a little it's a little
late you know we're you were having us
order our own food at restaurants at age
four five wow that's amazing right go
which is great because you feel this
kind of independence and now when I date
someone who tries to order for me I'm
like this is never gonna work because I
don't see as chivalrous I see it as
someone who's trying to take my autonomy
away from me damn dude you got some
deep-seated issues homie when I had a
restaurant and somebody goes I'm gonna
order for him light then you also go and
pay [ __ ] cuz if I don't like this my
family [ __ ] hope you take that
responsibility - you've got thrown right
back in the face they go you know what I
got this that's haiku you also got the
bill - then the [ __ ] or to me this
[ __ ] that I want oh god but but now
I think it's kind of coming back to them
in a really negative way because they're
unable well I wouldn't say they're
unable to respect us I think that right
now it's a lot of confusion I came out
to my parent my mom last February she's
actually what a first family member
outside of my cousin's that I came out
to so when I came out to my mom I had
level of I mean I was terrified the
whole drive over to my house I was
sobbing like just sobbing because
essentially my mom had called me a week
before and she said who is this woman
who is this woman that you're always
hanging out with and running to whenever
she calls and you're like going on trips
together like what's happening I just
got this really weird feeling and at the
time I was in Virginia and my I remember
I was in the car I was in the passenger
seat and my heart just dropped and I
knew this is the conversation that I've
been waiting to have with my mom for a
really long time like the better part of
a decade right and I'm like I can't
believe it's come down to a feeling like
a maternal feeling that she's had and
she's asking me these questions
frantically over the phone and I just
said my heart's racing and I just
remember saying okay I'm back in
California
tomorrow let me go home and then I'll
come visit you well sure and she said
okay well please yes please please
please call me back call me tomorrow
before your flight please units like I
just I need you to do this and I was
like okay I'll just call you later I
couldn't call her that whole day and the
next morning I wake up my hands are
sweating I've packed everything to go I
can't stop crying and I'm just feeling
like this moment of reckoning right it's
like she's gonna disown me I'm not gonna
have any family members anymore and for
me that's a huge blow because my mom's
like my best friend and so I go back to
LA I'm crying and at the time too I had
just come out of a relationship so I was
in the midst of a breakup and oh yeah
yes a whole story oh yeah we don't want
to go they don't want to go then we
don't have time for that boy no plus I'm
still mad at you for that so I go home
you know
I was living with Susan yeah and Lydia
and Ellen came over to my place I think
I think they came over like every night
before I went home and I was like crying
telling them you know
have no family anymore I don't know how
I'm gonna tell my mom and I remember it
was I think Susan or Ellen said
something like you know give your
parents a chance give them a chance to
surprise you because if you walk in
there defeated you're you know like
there's no positive outcome to this yeah
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
right and I just thought okay maybe I
can tell my mom I don't think I'm
prepared to tell the rest of my family
so I'm so anyway cut back to me crying
in the car like praying praying for an
hour saying please help me like I don't
know what to do I feel completely
hopeless and lost in this situation
because essentially I've like lived my
life very freely and the way I wanted
for a decade and now I'm having to go
home and explain myself and this is
someone that I've known for 31 years and
now I'm telling her you actually don't
know me whatsoever because here's this
massive thing that I've been hiding and
I remember that night that the girls
came over my mom had sent me a cacao oh
yeah
coke I was like this Korean messenger
thing for people who don't know and she
said in Korean she goes Eunice my heart
every time I think about you my heart is
broken open and tears stream down my
face because I love you so much
something like that like really
traumatic of course yeah and but of
course at the time too I'm like oh my
god I don't want to be breaking my
mother's heart like that broke me and
then that would cause more to end then
essentially when you cry so much your
eyes are so used to crying you can't
stop crying and then it anyway it's this
horrible vicious cycle so I'm home my
dad greets me at the door he's just like
hi yeah Eunice is home and then I'm like
hi dad and heart's like just and then my
mom is like I'm cooking in the kitchen
so I'm like okay this seems this seems
fine like this is normal we go into the
kitchen my mom's like okay food's almost
she's completely avoiding eye contact
with me I'm so nervous I don't know how
to behave in that moment and my dad's
just rambling on and on he's like asking
me about my work and asking me about my
life and that kind of calms me down
because now we're talking about
something that doesn't have anything to
do with then I'm like well maybe dad
doesn't know yet so this is good and
then we're eating and my dad and I are
really getting on and then my mom is
silent and my dad looks at her and he
goes hey why are you so quiet
why aren't you saying anything and she
looks up and she goes Eunice and I have
a few things that we need to talk about
before like God before I can join in on
this conversation heart drops food plops
out of my mouth it was like oh my god I
my dad immediately goes okay great see
you later runs out of the kitchen he's
scared of stairs right all yours yeah so
why do we have 17 locks on the door he
runs upstairs I'm like okay clearly he
knows something right but he's not
willing to be a part of this
conversation right now which is better
for me because I was so uncomfortable
and so my mom starts talking and the
first thing she says to me is you know
Eunice I've been doing a lot of research
and the first thing that I wanted to
tell you and I think this comes from a
nervousness too and I when I realized
that and I clocked that it's not just me
who's nervous she's equally as nervous
yo she's like I've read on like Korean
like Naver which is like Google that
homosexuality is harder to get out of
than drugs and and I was like that's so
funny
and I was like okay mom can I just
please please stop you right there she's
like yeah of cocaine and she like shuts
up and she's staring at me and she's so
much like fear behind her eyes and I
said look mom because she wanted you
just to say I'm not gay right and I said
you're I said look I've known that there
was something different about me since I
was six years old and the whole Drive
from LA to my parents house I told
myself don't cry when you're coming out
to your
because when you cry it takes away from
the severity and the realness and the
authenticity of what you're feeling you
really think yeah I don't I mean I was
always brought up to be like don't cry
don't cry don't cry but also I think
though there's a vulnerability in crying
but there's also a moment where when
you're telling someone something that
means that that means something real and
I don't know there's something about
that moment where I felt like I need to
tell you in a way that you understand
and I'm gonna be very logical and
explanatory about this and I'm gonna be
patient and sit here and listen but the
last thing I wanted to do was be like a
puddle right and so I'm telling her I
knew since I was six years old and all
of a sudden I'm I without any prompt I'm
like sobbing you know like full sobbing
like I can't breathe my mom gets up I'm
like holy [ __ ] she's gonna hit me or
she's gonna be like she's gonna drag me
out but I'm so I'm just so upset with
myself for crying and I'm also just so I
don't know I was just uh I was so sick
yeah my mom reaches over me and I'm like
bracing myself she grabs these napkins
and she's standing over me and she
starts wiping my face hmm
and she and I can feel her tears just oh
my gosh now I'm gonna cry but I can feel
her tears like hitting the top of my
head which in turn makes me sob harder
because I never want my mom to cry
because of me I never want her to feel
anything but pure joy and happiness when
she thinks of me right and she starts
wiping my face and she's like I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry that you've had to
like live with this for so long by
yourself and and then she's like and
then she's and then she kind of and I
felt like oh my god she she gets it or
she's sympathizing and then she says and
I'm so sorry it's my fault and I think
that's when the tears kind of stopped
cuz I said it's not your fault and I
really need you to understand that it's
not your fault it's no one's fault
it's just though it's just what it is
and then we kind of digressed and then
she started to ask me more pointed
questions about my sexuality in the
coming days and I thought well there
really is like light at the end of this
tunnel and then it just went south but
that was more recent what she doesn't
get itself for she isn't she's not
accepting of it I think I think Koreans
do this thing where they try and justify
anything negative um with an explanation
right hmm so it's like your daughter's
wants to marry a white dude it's like at
first it kills them and then they think
and then finally they come around
they're like well he's well he makes
really good money he treats her well
like that like you know it's like this
justification system and I think with my
mom at first it was like she saw me and
she sees her daughter who she loves so
much in pain and having this having held
this burden for 30 years and so she
sympathized and she understood
intuitively and then when she thought
about it in the weeks or months to come
she kind of backtracked and it was like
how do I explain this like what do I do
with this who's gonna understand this
like I think that's where she's stuck
right now and for me I don't need her to
justify it or explain it I just I just
want her to accept me for who I am
there's your dad no yeah yeah how's my
dad is he well okay I probably [ __ ]
shouldn't mention this but he was
extremely homophobic when we were
growing up like every male Korean all
the real Korean men I've ever known is
that for my dad really
that's very um whatever about a lot of
things so I remember when um you know
when was it prop a [ __ ] up a prop
eight came out right and then somebody
put the whole you know whatever ban prop
a [ __ ] on our lawn cuz my dad's a pastor
like that even know what it was what is
this and they're like oh we don't want
gay people to get married my dad's like
why pastor but for him pay for his thing
is like whether you give somebody
permission to get married or not mhm
doesn't change the fact that they're gay
so either way if it's like just from the
Christian perspective is like they're
still gay whether they get married or
not it doesn't make a difference right
so my desk but it's very just like c'est
la vie about that type of stuff kind of
just nuts what's what maybe that's why I
don't care you know what do you think he
would have said if he found out you were
gay I don't know I mean it would be a
very tough time I put him through some
[ __ ] though so he coming out as gay it's
just it's probably a lot nicer than all
the other stuff I put him through you
know if I would have exchanged all the
fights all of the you know explosions
everything else for me being gay I think
he would switch it he goes okay just to
be gay but I think I'm for sure if it's
a personal thing if it's his family as a
as a Christian pastor mm-hmm for sure it
would it would [ __ ] him up and it would
be something that he would have to go
through I don't know if he would disown
me per se but it would be hard for him
to understand but for me as an
individual I love my parents but I can
never live a lie I could I couldn't even
[ __ ] finish college because they
asked you to what the [ __ ] do you think
I would do about me coming out as gay it
has just been a man dicks my thing you
know I like dick yeah if anything else
we'll meet halfway I'll go find a gay
Korean guy you know we'll just do half
way well I think that's really nice but
I also think that it's much harder in
practice oh oh I'm I'm definitely not
downplaying it's a very death of course
so in theory you think god I could never
lie to them about anything I mean I used
to call my even after knowing my sexual
identity and coming to terms with it on
my own as a Christian Korean woman I
spoke to I mean I spoke to my mom like
two times a day we would have a
very strange relationship but it was
never something I could tell her and I
used to always say I'm not gonna tell
her unless I have found the partner that
I'm gonna end up with for the rest of my
life so it's like a double whammy yeah
it's like I'm gay and I'm gonna get
married so just gonna destroy her on the
CD it's very very kind of the only way
that's right I knew how to deal with
that and I thought well what if I end up
being single my whole life now I've just
destroyed my mother probably took years
off of her life and then now I'm telling
her oh but couldn't find anyone so so
what's the point of putting someone
through that in the Korean community I
mean I'm sure there's a lot of there's a
lot wrong with that but in the Korean
community I think that's the preference
yeah I mean to play the other side I
mean not to play the other side but just
to have a little empathy for your
parents and I think a lot of people when
they hear stories like this they just
immediately want to trash parents but
it's it's hard when you grow up a
certain way your whole life mm-hmm I
mean for those it's it kind of works
both ways right so in the sense of they
go
some people might hear this and they go
oh Eunice's parents or parents are
terrible but at the same time it's just
like in the same way you have your
identity of being a homosexual person
these people although it's not something
they were born with it's something that
they've lived with with their whole life
and now I said they had to change their
perspective immediately it's going to be
a struggle so there has to be empathy on
that so absolutely I mean I definitely
don't want to allude to the fact that my
parents are bad people like in my heart
I understand their perspective yeah and
I think that's why it makes it harder
for me because I fully understand and
empathize with their perspective yeah
but there's this real lack of being able
to open their minds even a tiny bit to
mine but that of course comes from their
own experience you know like it makes
total sense to me so there's no villain
in this it's just it's just us trying to
come to some kind of understanding with
each other I mean they're going to have
to if they want you to stay in their
lives I mean that they're just going to
just continue to ignore you
forever I mean what what is that what is
the point of that right because they're
taking me as a personal betrayal and
it's not personal it's personal to you
but it shouldn't be personal to them or
anybody else right that's in your family
that's gonna take it that way because
that's how people see a lot of things
when they see somebody go through
something else they just think about oh
this is what I'm going through but it's
not about you you know the whole
coming-out process wasn't about you and
your identity it was about my thing the
ripple effect is that you're affected by
it and that's just a hard thing for
people to swallow right well I know we
digressed but so my dad was extremely
homophobic yeah yeah but she's actually
been handling it in the most gracious
way possible so I've never out rightly
told him anything but he is very aware
of the situation because you were gay
since day one I don't think so you over
here just to Barbie dolls and no Ken you
know when I was in my late 20s every day
every time I'd see him he'd say Oh
Eunice when are you gonna meet a boy you
need a sort of family and like my dad
like that's so weird cuz usually it's
the moms doing that and ever since that
day he has never said anything like that
to me again
which I think speaks volumes and he's
also he doesn't I don't know if he's
uncomfortable with it and I'm really I'm
really nervous to approach him with it
because because it's never been
discussed but he shows so much more love
and kindness towards me I mean he always
has but I feel like particularly more
since this whole experience with my
family and he's just what I hear from my
sister is that he realizes that this
isn't something that he can change and
if it is something like he can perhaps
change which you know he can't it's
through prayer right but maybe it's not
my changing but it's his heart yeah and
so of course I can't tell you what he's
praying or what he's wishing for but
what I know is that he has he's been so
patient through this whole process he's
never said anything out of line he
stopped asking me about guys he's just
been he's been such an incredible like
silent support that it just took me to
an it developed like a new level of our
relationship probably harder for your
mom because you're a lot closer to her
so everything just hurts a little more
yeah I mean your dad is it's different
when people who are closer to you it's
like even when you're in a relationship
um your friends can joke about the same
thing but if your person you're with
jokes about some [ __ ] like that it might
affect you a little different right
that's how it is with me and Mariel like
I'll I'll say a joke that literally
maybe one of her friend said and
reference it as she's like what the [ __ ]
and a whole lot of second Becky see the
same thing the same thing you can't she
said she was yeah but the way Becky said
it it was funny that's so true that's so
true people closest to us can definitely
Emily yeah just say anybody who's
closest to your heart for some reason
you interpret it the wrong way
every [ __ ] or maybe we just take our
relationships with them for granted and
it's like well doesn't matter if I get
upset I can reveal my true self because
they're gonna come around and they're
gonna understand me they know me not me
you mistreat me I'll cut you out for
life like a cancer but actually do you
know what today is what it's the three
year anniversary of the pulse nightclub
Massacre you call that an anniversary
well I mean what is it what is that it's
the orlando shootings join pride
oh it's been three [ __ ] years that's
crazy
yeah do you do we label that as an
anniversary work that's a recurring is
an anniversary like the anniversary of
9/11 like doesn't think oh it's be call
it anniversary so the remembrance the
right I mean I guess anniversary does a
little a three year celebration of the
massacre that was the Orlando gay club
right and somebody was it was it a hate
crime bill or was it just because I got
was crazy no I mean it was definitely a
hate crime was it I can't remember what
that article was about but there was a
weird interesting story
and I heard it was it it was a dude that
got would reject I'm actually I'm not
gonna say anything cuz I might be
[ __ ] this up but in my mind how I
remember it was the guy that shot up the
place where everybody that they assumed
was about to come out like he was and he
he was mentally unstable but he was gay
I don't know I said that he frequent
that club a lot but he wasn't openly gay
but um it was some kind of weird thing
like that well he's a 29 year old
security guard yeah called Omar Mateen
it was some way it was a weird story
don't quote me on that [ __ ] I might be
making this into a way more in cheese or
allegiance to Isis okay I heard some
weird [ __ ] though I I don't know
I'm definitely [ __ ] up the story was
he also ice cream man well apparently
here it says like he didn't know it was
a gay nightclub I don't know it's
interesting man how how there's so much
tragedy going on in this world and how
much is publicized right after a while I
get I got desensitized to a lot of this
stuff and it's kind of sad because 9/11
has stuck in my [ __ ] head and it's
like stuck in my head for the rest of my
life right but we just had a even bigger
massacre in Vegas with that [ __ ] right
some people don't even remember it I'm
talking about it and they go what was
that and it's insane you know I was in
that's so funny you mentioned that cuz
two weeks ago is in Vegas from Memorial
Day holiday and we took a lift after the
Penn & Teller show to go back to the
Venetian and we had this like nice guy
and like dress shirt button to the top
like blonde from the Midwest and we were
talking and we were stopped at this
massive intersection and all of a sudden
like seven police cars started going and
they cut through the intersection and no
one could cross and he like had this
visceral like reaction to it and we were
looking at him like okay and he's like
oh my god I just I have I think I have
PTSD and we're like right okay
he was telling us about it and how
terrifying it was for everyone and you
know that's an experience I'm sure he's
never gonna forget you're right but I
think with the internet now we hear so
much and unless it directly impacts us
like we all know where we were at 9/11
when you happen I know exactly where I
was yeah me too
it's I'm saying that that ripple effect
is crazy because even that Orlando
massacre thing it I think prior to
social media and this everything being
so just put out there all the [ __ ]
time when these are catastrophic events
happen it just sticks in our memory
right and I'm not I'm not trying to you
know do comparison in terms of like
catastrophic caliber to diff all these
different events but what I'm saying
it's like those are still huge you know
yeah I know it was an attack on our on
our country like 9/11 was but still the
biggest massacre in the United States
he'll this day happened in Vegas and
there are people who don't remember it I
actually think the biggest massacre was
um pulse I think I think it was a Vegas
one I think it was labeled as a bit we
could look at well how much money you
want to put on that okay I know this is
a terrible terrible but okay let's see
I'm my phone's just gonna start giving
me weird suggestions but face slap
that's the bet here we go mmm did not
agree to that in you and you face slap
me I'm losing all my teeth just those
big-ass hands of yours wait we might we
might both be wrong oh really
okay wow there's a lot this is a really
this is actually a really sad yeah this
very sad I don't like this at all okay
let's see that's the craziest thing I
don't know I mean you know when when
events like this happened to there's
just this whole talk about gun laws and
gun restriction and I don't even know
what the [ __ ] to feel about that there's
so many different sides to it
okay wait if it's between those two
you're right in your face because it's
50 I don't know do you wanna hear these
two yeah I would like to give this
important okay so the Vegas shooting
which was in 2017 October first was 59
including the gunman and then 851
wounded and 422 of them from gunfire
yeah see that's a fat difference and
then Orlando which was 2016 June 12th it
was 50 including the gunman which is
still I mean Chelsea's raised [ __ ] is
you're I mean you're also limited to
like in like a closed in space yeah
where are you gonna go nowhere
venerable yeah I mean both scenarios
it's terrifying right that's why I don't
go to concerts I don't do nothing right
like you just feel in those movie
theater shootings that really
traumatized me I remember going to film
after that happened just being like okay
I need to be aware of where I am there
was this kid um when I went to Colorado
to do a stand-up show I went back to
that college to the the same time next
year for the same same event so when I
was in Colorado this kid came up to me
and I don't know if he's gonna be
listening to this but he was a very
large kid bigger than I was at the time
just palms sweaty because I shook his
hand he's just shaking he couldn't make
eye contact he was looking at the floor
and he came up to me and he goes he goes
this is my first time that I ever left
my than my my bedroom in a long time I
was like what why like what happened he
goes I was in that theater in Colorado
when that shooting happened and I
haven't been able to leave my bedroom
since and I came out to the show to come
see you because of you know you make me
laugh you make me feel better
wow I was [ __ ] mind blown right and he
says like well since then I gained a lot
of weight and I'm trying to this is a
part of why losing weight too and he
goes I want to lose weight so the next
year I came back to Colorado this kid
came up to me just full of energy very
bright whatever he comes up he goes hey
man do you remember me and I was like
nah man I don't remember you at all he
goes I was that kid that was in that
Colorado shooting the theater shooting
last year and a completely different
person he lost like I don't know how
much weight he lost like 60 70 pounds
Wow and he just was a completely
different person that's awesome yeah and
it's so weird too because you know
during that time I mean that kid doesn't
even know but I was always in a space of
whether I should stay
you tube or leave and you know because I
had my sights set on something bigger or
greater in my opinion of whatever that
is but hearing those personal stories
always continued from no matter what I'm
doing to still put up content on YouTube
just because yeah it's not like an end
goal for me but there that there's this
positive effect that it has on on young
people that it just kind of hard for me
to step away from yeah cuz you hear
those type of stories and you never
think that what you say or what you do
will affect them in that type of way
because humour for me is something that
I think it's it's very cathartic right
so it takes a lot of these Bad's that
you would that's why I don't like it
when people say you shouldn't joke about
this isn't that in comedy because just
cuz it makes it doesn't make you laugh
or makes you feel bad doesn't mean that
it's not helping somebody else because
some people just need that need to joke
about serious things in a certain way to
get over it that's how I think a lot of
people deal with their issues so in the
comedy club anyway in the comedy club
scene maybe not so much in videos or
whatever you should be a little smarter
about that but in the comedy club in the
writers room I think you should allow
people to say their things and kind of
work it out but yeah look at that well
you know what time's already up see how
fast that Wow
and you didn't cry I told you you
weren't gonna cry you heartless [ __ ] so
close I know I didn't I didn't probe you
though because you said you didn't want
to cry cause you've been crying all me
yeah yeah I would have I would have just
asked the right question okay well I'm
not gonna respond but what would have
been a question I just would have done
fall I just let you speak and then let
it happen I was gonna make you cry
though I swear to God I just do it for
the views baby no I'm kidding but see
this is what I'm talking about why I
said I couldn't do a video on this
because I don't have this type of
insight about coming out I don't know
what that's like
ellen:oh like I'm the authority of gay
it's not Authority but it's a very with
you are my authority because you are the
closest gay person that I know like
you're like my one of my type friends
everybody else is in the acquaintance
and so I don't really care to ask them
too much or I don't feel close enough to
ask them to tell the personal story you
know and your situations very unique
especially cuz you're a korean-american
and you grew up in a Christian house
yeah do you know what's funny after cuz
well is so like shocked and relief from
it I was telling my friends cuz they
were like what happened are you okay and
do you know Vivian being she did white
rabbit she played Jenny in okay yeah
they knew Ali Wong fell yeah she goes
Yunis can I can I write a film about
your experience smells like I know whoot
Li not I was like I need to protect my
family right now and I don't think
that's a good idea
people always ask that [ __ ] you know
when you tell us like dude can I write
something no you [ __ ] cannot you
piece of [ __ ] absolutely not it's my
personal storm I write this
it's my [ __ ] story yeah but see this
is so cool though because I like
bringing people in yeah I mean we could
always joke about stuff and make make
jokes which is fine and people enjoy
that too but I don't know this is
something that I just don't know
anything about I don't know what it's
like just [ __ ] scissor dude and just
back out bow yeah that's the joke part I
like it because you let me make these
jokes it makes me laugh makes me feel
good I mean if it makes you feel good
then hey I know but let me tell you
something if you ever need to fool your
parents that you married a man right
here well let's just get this out there
you're giving me your sperm right okay
perfect what you're gonna we're gonna
have these big handed babies these huge
big handed babies David your hands are
massive well it's appropriate to my size
but your hands are the same size as mine
when I hold your hands even our hands
are not the same size I hold your hands
it feels like I have a third arm all
right guys well you could catch us on
Spotify iTunes all these other stuff
cast box if you're on iTunes leave us
that five star remember to comment below
and share and let me know what you want
us to talk about and Eunice oh by the
way if you don't know who Eunice is I
work with her on [ __ ] what she does is
that she dresses people up tell them
what you do let me get these you know
you don't have that designer cos see
that's the word a costume designer slash
stylist yeah so she made [ __ ] happen
with the minimal budget that we had
which was [ __ ] pennies so this lady
right here though is a [ __ ] G she's
worked on a lot of big [ __ ] you could
tell she went to New York alone
you know this [ __ ] over here when I
first met her she goes I want some over
jeans which is just a flat-out lie can I
add I need some rocket you flat out
right up in California and you said Rafi
like you need to extend this session
because we need again to a debater okay
we'll work on that next time when I
invite you and I definitely gotta bring
Susan on too so we could just [ __ ]
love that girl by the way she's
hilarious she's so funny yeah all right
guys we'll see you guys next time